hey guys tim ferriss here before we jump
into this episode I'm gonna do something
I very rarely do and that is to make a
direct ask with hat in hand my brand new
book just came out today it is called
tribe of mentors subtitle short life
advice from the best in the world
if you like the podcast you will love
this book
I reached out to 130 people who are the
best at what they do in sports investing
business acting directing you name it we
got it cryptocurrency done and it turned
out better than I ever could have
expected many of my friends think of all
my books it is the easiest to read the
easiest to use so check it out please
take a look I put out so much free
material the podcast is free the
700-plus blog posts are free every once
in a while I put out something like this
and it's not that expensive so please
take a look
tribe of mentors dot-com and it does
make a great holiday gift or gift for
others there's something for everybody
in here it is really a
choose-your-own-adventure guide a buffet
of options for improving your life both
in business and in the personal sphere
so take a look I appreciate you taking a
look tribe of mentors calm or anywhere
the books are sold at this altitude
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking can I ask
you a personal question
I must - any organism living tissue over
metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by zip recruiter you may
have heard them everywhere they're
growing like crazy they're an innovative
platform for doing several things but
especially improving the hiring process
making it slick and elegant and easy one
of the hardest parts of running any
business growing any business is finding
and hiring the right team I've seen this
firsthand in close to a hundred startups
now god I'm getting old from all over
the world at different stages of growth
and nothing can quite drain your
resources and cost you time and money
like making mistakes in hiring Zipp
recruiter developed their own system and
their own platform for helping you to
solve two of the biggest problems and
bottlenecks for employers posting jobs
easily and then making it even easier to
find the best candidates unlike other
job sites zipper cruder does in effect
the opposite of what you'd expect so
they do not depend on candidates finding
you their technology finds the right
candidate for you and in fact more than
80% of the jobs posted on zip recruit or
return a qualified candidate based on
your criteria that you select in just 24
hours
so no more juggling email reviewing
hundreds of unqualified candidates I've
been there done that don't recommend it
we're dealing with calls to the office
etc none of that simply screen rate and
manage your candidates all in one place
unzip recruiters dashboard and is a
listener of the Tim Ferriss show thanks
for that zip recruiter wants to allow
you to start posting jobs and trying
their services for free so if you're
thinking of hiring somebody you need to
find an executive assistant you need to
find a developer whatever it might be
try not just visit zip recruiter com
forward slash Tim and you can experience
just how zip recruiter has been used by
businesses of all different sizes to
find the most qualified job candidates
again that's zip recruiter dot-com
forward slash Tim check it out
give it a spin this episode is brought
to you by helix sleep I recently moved
into a new home and when I needed beds
where did I go I went to helix and I
paid for them with my own monies I tried
all sorts of mattresses some of you saw
me soliciting feedback and ideas on
social media I tested a ton and I ended
up on helix they offer mattresses
personalized to your preferences and
sleeping style without costing thousands
of dollars
check it out heal it sleep calm
forward-slash Tim and you can take their
very simple two to three minutes sleep
quiz to get started that's a diagnostic
and they can build your mattress from
there and ensure that it is something
you will absolutely love the quiz helps
determine the type of mattress that is
best for you by asking all sorts of
questions about your sleep behavior such
as if you tend to lie on your back side
or stomach as well as your body type for
couples they can even personalize each
side of the mattress their customer
service is phenomenal my assistant my
researcher I had them all test helix and
the customer service is really
outstanding the mattress arrives within
a week and the shipping is completely
free you can try the mattress then for a
hundred nights and if you're not happy
they'll pick it up and offer a full
refund so check it out to personalize
your sleep experience visit helix sleep
comm forward slash Tim and you can get
$50 off of your custom mattress so check
it out helix sleep comm forward slash
Tim
oh hello boys and girls and friendly
little Mogwai that's what that was this
is Tim Ferriss and thank you for
listening
yet another episode of my meandering
conversations in this case it's going to
be a little bit unusual instead of the
typical interview format where I ask
other people many questions including
the 11 questions that I asked everyone
130 plus world-class performers in the
book tribe of mentors check it out in
five of mentors dot-com
instead of that I am going to do what
thousands of you have asked me to do and
that is answer those very same 11
questions which have been refined over
many hundreds of interviews and I hope
my answers don't disappoint these were
all recorded in the capital of weird
Austin Texas which i think is
appropriate so I hope you enjoy this
solo episode and that you glean
something from the chaotic unplanned
experience that has been my life and as
always thank you for listening in the
last five years what beliefs behaviors
or habits have most positively impacted
my life a few come to mind the first
came after my good friend Matt Mullenweg
very impressive guy considered the lead
developer of WordPress which now powers
30 plus percent of the entire internet
also runs a company that happens to be
worth more than a billion dollars he
recommended that I read an article
called the tail end by Tim urban on blog
called wait but why and it makes the
point very clearly also with visuals
that and I'm gonna paraphrase this by
the time you leave for college or by the
time you graduate from high school
you've spent more than 80% of the total
number of hours you will ever spend with
your parents before they die right let's
think about that I encourage you to read
it but that led me to make the decision
to take my parents and when possible my
brother is a real job on a trip every
six months so
last few years I've sat down with my
parents for my brother or one of my
parents to think up a dream location
where could I take them where haven't
they been so could I take my mom to
Paris she's never been to Paris I've
never spent time in Paris really so I
took my family to Paris and so basically
every December or January around the
holidays
and then again around June or July I try
to take my entire family on a trip
somewhere and for those people watching
this or hearing this doesn't have to be
fancy in my case though I'm thinking
about any place that could be really fun
it could be just a national park
somewhere in the US right going to Zion
and that has made our relationships
better than they have ever been
right now 40 now and in the last two
years I just feel our bonding ability
our care for one another our love for
one another has just gone through the
roof and it really made me appreciate
the finite time that we have left that
we all have left but especially with my
parents and that's just been a really
joyful discovery so thanks Matt the next
one that comes to mind is a belief and
this is a very recent one I always
viewed positive self-talk
and being nice to myself as
self-indulgent and optional I prefer to
just view myself as an instrument for
competing doing well achieving and after
reading books like radical acceptance
for instance by Tara brach which is
spectacular and realizing how much of
the things that I want to work on our
fix can be traced back to negative
self-talk and critical self-talk the
belief that if you want to love others
fully you have to love yourself period
full stop end of story you can't berate
yourself constantly and think that you
can fully express love to other people I
just don't think it's possible so that's
the belief that in order to love others
fully you have to love yourself which
believe me as someone who's tried to be
the Terminator his whole life
on some level pains me to admit but I
think it's true and last I would say two
things number one and do not explore
this without professional legal and
medical advice but is looking into and
supporting research related to
psychedelic research and if you want to
hear a bit more about that or read a bit
more about that you can listen to my
podcast episodes with James Fadiman FA
di ma n or Dan angle Eng le closely
related to that although you might not
think is meditating on a daily basis I
went through a huge burnout period right
after the 4-hour chef and to people who
are world-class performers Chase Jarvis
incredibly successful photographer also
start-up CEO has really killed it in
many many fields and then Rick Rubin
perhaps the most legendary music
producer of all time both said in effect
dude have you ever thought about trying
Transcendental Meditation and I had a
lot of pushback a lot of pushback I was
like I seems culty and they charge you
to give you a mantra are you kidding not
gonna do it and they said what do you
have to lose
seems like you have no downside here
because you're sort of at at redline and
I did it and it doesn't have to be
trance no meditation but meditating 20
minutes certainly first thing in the
morning and then when possible before
dinner at some point has completely
changed my life in terms of being able
to capitalize on that gap that small gap
between event or stimulus and my
response and that little gap that little
gap is your life that little gap is
reality so being able to widen that gap
just enough so that I can choose my
response instead of being completely
reactive has been huge so those are a
few things that have dramatically
changed my life in the last five years
so purchases of less than $100 that have
most improved my life in recent memory
because there are many purchases of less
than hundred olives there a few right
off the bat number one is this hat this
is the Sitka Dakota beanie and it's camo
just so people don't see your head when
you're walking around you look like the
Headless Horseman in your turquoise
shirt but extremely comfortable hat that
for whatever reason I Knight I can't
properly explain this I can wear say in
warmer temperatures like 60 just because
I don't have much coverage I can also
wear it sub-freezing and it works in
both environments I first got exposed to
this it gives a hunting brand that's
kind of like the the Lululemon the most
comfortable clothing in the hunting
world really high quality gear when I
was in Colorado and I travel with this
everywhere I also use it as a murse man
purse so I'll stick say a piece of
recording equipment into this hat to
protect it because it's semi padded so
this travels with me constantly that's
number one might as well show you this
number two which is spray Zink this is
there's-- ink spray which is the zinc
gluconate and I use this for immune
support so this travels in the side of
my backpack and I wall spray like Binaca
but five or six sprays around the mouth
and I'll do this two or three times
probably per day when I'm traveling and
I've found it as it appears at least to
me to make a substantial difference if
there are a lot of people getting sick
and continuing to get sick coughing and
so on on a trip or on a plane this helps
me not to succumb so this is always with
me the next one that is always with me
and all these items travel with me 24/7
effectively they live in my backpack
this is the rubs device and no it is not
a massage parlor with black windows it
is what looks like a golf ball and it
has these little nubs on it
it was gifted to me this is very very
cheap it's like six dollars gifted to
by Amelia moons Thank You Amelia who is
a four-time world champion in obstacle
course racing and you roll out your feet
or your hands or your forearms in my
case with this device and it is
incredible how much it relieves pain
throughout the body if you just roll out
your feet properly which is something I
picked up
not only from Amelia bloomer but from
Edie cone who is the most successful
legendary power lifter in the history of
the world I think he ded lifted 901
pounds at 220 something insane like that
and a lot of back pain leg pain in my
experience goes away when you just rub
out your feet so if I landed a hotel or
when I wake up after much travel I use
this on the feet next up we have this
device this isn't the most interesting
angle though that is the most
interesting angle this is the Logitech
keys to go keyboard and it holds a
charge for a very very long time and I
stick this in the laptop pocket why
because I like to work and say
restaurants I like to type I like to
brainstorm in restaurants but I don't
wanna have a laptop out or if my laptop
has a problem and I can't use it I still
want to be able to type and not poke at
my iPhone screen so I will take my
iPhone lean it against say a glass of
iced tea or wine or whatever and then I
will pair it to this keyboard and I can
type an entire chapter out it's really
cool and people don't even notice
necessarily that I'm working they just
think I'm a crackhead staring at my iced
tea for two hours straight alright the
last step and this is increasingly
important as I travel to louder and
louder cities let's say in some cases is
following Mac's pillow soft silicon
putty and this is what it looks like
these are earplugs and they are not foam
and what this allows you to do is
sleep very very very well and that
includes laying on your side so what
happens if you say roll-up foam earplugs
stick them in your ear and they lay on
their side you feel like you have a nerf
ice pick being jabbed into your eardrum
which is not very comfortable and I find
these two also dampen sound more
effectively than foam typically
fantastic so those are a handful of the
purchases less than hundred dollars that
have most impacted my life and continue
to they travel with me 24/7 all right
it's sill what would I put on a
billboard if I could put one message on
a billboard to get to millions or
billions of people it would be you are
the average of the five people you
associate with most which also happens
to be probably the best advice that I
received between the ages of 10 and say
15 I remember that a mentor at the time
who I think was borrowing from Jim Rohn
ROH n who happens to be the mentor of
Tony Robbins long story but he left a
message on my answering machine with
tapes remember those kids and he left
that bit of advice I said just remember
you're the average of the five people
you associate with most right and that
means financially emotionally physically
mentally you are going to be the average
of the five people you spend the most
time around all right
so choose those people as well as you
can
what do I do when I feel unfocused or
overwhelmed there are a few things first
I have a short checklist am i eating
enough all right so it's very
fashionable with intermittent fasting to
skip breakfast skip that meal skip
another meal for myself I've realized
unless I am in ketosis unless I am on a
ketogenic diet or fasting or have
ketones in my blood which is an
alternate fuel to glucose I need to eat
and of course you can supplement with
exhaust ketones but am i eating enough
if I skip breakfast and it's 1 p.m. and
I haven't had lunch and I'm feeling
unfocused or overwhelmed I probably
don't need to sit there and journal on
my existential dilemmas I need to eat
some [ __ ] macadamia nuts and maybe
have some beans or salad or something
like that all right it's a simple simple
simple the second would be am i
consuming too much caffeine real simple
for me if I'm feeling anxious
overwhelmed very often if I want to
achieve a more zen-like state there are
at least two things I can do and one is
meditate twice a day which I like to do
doesn't always happen meditate twice a
day and do all of these other things
related to cultivating peace of mind the
second one is stop consuming so much
caffeine alright real real real simple
then last are a few tactical and
strategic questions and being
overwhelmed and unfocused I think are
quite different things typically
sometimes they come along together there
are two questions or I should say two
pairs or groups of questions that I use
a lot the first one is an 80/20 analysis
and there are two questions as part of
them and I put this on paper always on
paper because I want to trap my thoughts
on paper to see if they hold any weight
see if there's any insight to see what
is ridiculous maybe I have worries that
once I put them down or really unfounded
and kind of ludicrous first question is
what are the 20% of activities or people
that are producing 80% or more of the
results and positive emotional states
that I want the positive emotional
states part is really important
all right so you spend one or two pages
on that the second part is the opposite
what are the 20% of activities
responsibilities or people that are
producing 80% or more of the pain the
headache and the negative emotional
states that I would prefer not to have
do another page or two and then the last
question if you're engaged with a
specific project or relationship could
be anything really is very simple what
would this look like if it were easy
thanks very much if we're type A
personality we've competed in school
we've competed next we've competed in
y&z we are trained by ourselves to
believe that if we're not red lining if
we're not overcome with effort that
we're not doing a good job
we're not trying hard enough and I think
that often leads us to seek complicated
paths with many many moving pieces so
what would this look like if it were
easy so for instance if I'm having
trouble with a book and I have three
months left to write it I'll ask myself
what would this look like if it were
easy what if I had to finish this book
in a week if I had a gun to my head or a
gun to my dog's head or Molly
and I had to save Molly what would I do
all right you have a week that's it
period how would you write this book and
that carrot gets rid of a lot of fluff
and I started saying all right well how
could I use money instead of time to fix
this problem how could I ask other
people for help instead of trying to do
it all myself in this situation what
would this look like if it were easy and
you can find a lot of gems that way and
just expect 95% of you write down is
going to potentially be ludicrous and
you should come up with the absurd right
don't edit when you're putting stuff
down but within that you might find one
or two things and you're like that's it
now I can save 80% of my headache 80% of
my angst because I don't have to do it
the hard way and then you can find an
elegant solution that produces an even
better product even better outcome so
those are a few of the things that I
regularly do when I'm feeling
overwhelmed or unfocused or distracted
so what is my favorite fail here the
failure or a failure that set me up for
later success there many I mean I have
struck out a lot and it's important to
remember to say babe ruth's right I'm
ranking also the strikeout King and I'm
not saying I'm Babe Ruth in either
capacity but one that comes to mind that
is relatively fresh is the 4-hour chef
4-hour chef was my third book and I'm
very proud of it I think it's a I was
gonna say fantastic book that sounds a
little self-indulgent but I've put a lot
of effort into it I think it is a solid
book but it was the first major book
acquired by Amazon publishing so Amazon
announced that it was going to compete
head-to-head in a way with publishers by
forming its own imprint basically and
the book was boycotted by everybody
imaginable
so Barnes and Noble I want to say Costco
Walmart all of these big-box stores
would not distribute the book Indy's
also most Indies would not carry the
book so despite the fact that I felt
like we had a great product it sold a
small fraction of what I hoped what
certainly I think most people on the
team hoped it would and that was really
really painful was also my first four
color book and I thought it would be a
good idea to take 30 40 % of the
photographs myself to learn how to do
photography it turns out it you probably
want to tackle those one at a time and
not at the same time and it was brutal I
mean I had I would say a nervous
breakdown during that period my
relationship suffered I wasn't getting
enough sleep I was using stimulants to
keep awake it was bad time for a lot of
reasons and I was burned out so after
that I was completely depleted and I
decided in the process of promoting the
4-hour chef because I had done handful
of podcasts like Joe Rogan podcast Marc
Maron and which is WTF Nerdist Chris
Hardwick and so on and I really enjoyed
them I could be myself what if I just
took a break no more books I'm gonna
stop books and I will do six episodes
Podcast we're I'm asking the questions
because it would allow me to develop
skills and relationships that would
transcend that so I get better at asking
questions that get better at fixing
verbal tics and that could be applied to
later projects later books but never
really thought much of it so I proceeded
to do the podcast pretty quick and dirty
first episode get sloppily drunk with
Kevin Rose my close friend it's an
embarrassing first episode and ended up
falling in love with it and now the
podcast generates 10 times I would say
the annual revenue of all of my books
combined I still love doing it I've done
more than 300 episodes has more than 200
million downloads and the vast majority
of people who know me that is as say
fans or consumers of anything I do and
mention the podcast if they seem in the
streets you mean a coffee shop they
mention a specific episode of the
podcast they don't even mention the
books and that's totally fine with me
so I would say that set me up for a lot
of what I'm doing now couldn't be
happier so thanks for that failure
universe so books I have gifted the most
other people there are many the first
that comes to mind is any collection of
the letters from a stoic or more
commonly known in academic circles as
the moral letters to Luke ileus by
Seneca so I actually gave away these for
free because they're in the public
domain with illustrations and so on as
the Tao of Seneca because I've given
away hundreds and thousands of copies it
really teaches you what I consider
perhaps the ultimate operating system
for thriving in high stress environments
at least one of them then I would say
also because I read nothing but
nonfiction for more than a decade I
really like to gift people I know Taipei
driven people fiction because I think
many of the principles and truths
contained in stories are better absorbed
through fiction Zorba the Greek
specifically stands out which chronicles
the adventures of this very brainy very
analytical person which I see is more
myself who
all manner of mistakes in life because
of that and then this free willing crazy
person
Zorba the Greek so I highly highly
recommend that book and then also
there's a book called stranger in a
strange land by Robert Heinlein which is
incredible and if you've ever wondered
where the word grok oh i grok that i
don't rock that where that came from
it's commonly used in tech circles came
from that book and it's about a Martian
developing as a human being on earth
it's a spectacular spectacular book and
I would say last but certainly not least
would be surely I think it is surely
you're joking mr. Fineman along those
lines you'll find it and it is a book
written by Richard Fineman incredible
physicist involved with Manhattan
Project but also a polymath and had
taught himself how to play the bongos
how to crack safes how to paint which he
learned doing in strip clubs fascinating
hilarious guy expert at problem-solving
and also a very very very famous teacher
he could take complex physics concepts
and break them down to the point where
all he needed was say an apple and a pen
and he could explain something that
would normally take years of prereqs so
those are a few of the books that I have
gifted the most other people
so questions let's talk about questions
why our question is important questions
are critically important because first
and foremost thinking what goes on here
is largely asking yourself questions and
answering them secondly if you want to
get anything in life chances are it's
inside someone else's head the knowledge
the skills the blueprint and the pickaxe
for getting that gold is in the form of
questions all right so there are a few
things you can do to improve questions
number one is study questions watch
inside the Actors Studio listen to Terry
Gross listen to podcasts whether mine or
Joe Rogan's or others so that you can
borrow questions and test them on other
people and there are few things to
consider when you're formulating
questions number one is can it be
answered relatively quickly so for
instance if you found someone you
idolize you're in an elevator oh my god
it's Jimmy Fallon if you asked Jimmy a
question could he come up with a really
concrete answer in five seconds or less
the answer's no find a different
question for you or for other people so
what is your favorite book for instance
not a good question
because people have read hundreds or
thousands of books in many cases but
what book or books have you gifted the
most to other people it's gonna be a
short list the search query is really
refined it's fast click alright much
like asking yourself what makes me happy
is not really a great questions too
broad and it takes too long to search
but let's just say what makes me feel
most relieved after work when I get home
or what activities which people all
right now we're more refined you can
answer it much more quickly and it's
more actionable think also of the
sequence of questions so if you want to
ask someone as I do very often a
question that could be kind of heavy or
really involved like what would you put
on a billboard if you had a gigantic
billboard metaphorically speaking to
reach millions or billions of people
what would you put on it
alright that's that's a fair amount of
pressure and people in my case know they
might get
so to get them warmed up and ready for
that I don't lead with that I'll ask
them other questions that are much much
easier and less intimidating
so what purchase of a hundred dollars or
less has most positively impacted your
life in the last say year a recent
memory or the books question and that
gets them flowing it gets them engaged
and then I can ask a question like that
another trick you can use when you ask
what might be a difficult question is
you can give an example so it could be a
personal example or it could be
something else
if I ask someone what is something
absurd that you love doing because I
want that little shred of personality I
don't want to just have the actionable
business stuff I want to get to know
them as a human and I will then say well
for instance the number five five five
is good luck to me for many reasons so
when it appears on my phone I take a
screenshot and dot die elaborate a
little bit or Cheryl Strayed or wrote
wild likes to disassemble sandwiches and
rearrange all the ingredients so each
bite is uniform that gives them 30
seconds to think about their answer and
gives them some examples all right a few
things you should not do if you meet
someone who is say just above your
weight class in terms of professional
development and you want to connect with
them don't ask them questions that you
could answer on google number one all
right number two don't ask them really
broad questions they couldn't
conceivably answer quickly right what
should I do
what advice would you give me for
succeeding these are not good terms
if you can't define success in say ten
words or less get rid of it lose it from
the question all right and I would
encourage you to strive to be interested
in the form of good questions if you
seek to be perceived as interesting stop
talking start thinking about questions
and then stop and listen
one of the commonalities one of the
patterns the spot really quickly if you
interview hundreds of world-class
performers and I just interviewed 130 or
so for my new book tribal mentors is the
fact that they have consistent morning
routines they have some type of recipe a
boot up sequence that they use to win
the day in some fashion and it ranges
from for instance mindfulness and that
could be mindfulness meditation where
you find say Evan Williams who is well
known for blogger Twitter also medium
who spends time every morning as I do
with some type of meditative practice
could be insight it could be a trans
identity you could use an app like
headspace which i think is a great place
to start and it trains you it allows you
to practice becoming more aware and less
reactive so that you're not thrown off
by the unexpected challenges and
problems of the day and that helps you
to be much more productive and much more
centered you can achieve that in other
ways gratitude is a common element so
Tim O'Reilly who's just an incredible
entrepreneur thinker writer and thought
leader in Silicon Valley goes for a run
and will take a photograph of a single
flower on his run every morning right
and this teaches you to pause to pause
and to assess how your se responding to
things so that is a really beautiful
practice that can be done with gratitude
lists I use something called the
five-minute journal but Whitney Cummings
incredible stand-up comedian writer and
much more also has gratitude lists and
this is say naming three things that
you're grateful for each morning tony
robbins does this Brian Grazer
incredibly well known iconic TV and film
producer also does this I think he's had
a hundred and eighty Emmy nominations or
something like that and that achieves
very much the same thing of present
state awareness and looking for the
positive as opposed to fixating on the
negative and last but not least you have
Jocko willing retired Navy SEAL
commander who will lay out his clothes
his workout clothing the night before so
that there's no conscious decision
required were willpower or lack thereof
could intercede his clothing is ready
he's already set his to-do list for the
next day wakes up at he wakes up at 4:30
that's not quite when I wake up and
grabs the clothes boom directly to the
gym and he has a home gym where he does
his workout this is also very common
where people recognize these very busy
very driven people that if it's
inconvenient to work out they probably
won't do it so Jacko has home gym where
barbell plates squat rack three sets of
rings at different heights a kettlebell
and you're good to go that's all you
need so there's a few of the things that
I've seen repeatedly in different forums
with hundreds of top performers that
they use to win the morning so they can
win the day so in recent memory what
have I become better say last year or
two at saying no to and are there any
approaches that have worked well for me
there are quite a few so if you were to
look at my inbox right now I do not
believe in inbox zero as a goal I have
more than three hundred and forty
thousand unread email and I don't give
out my email freely 90% of those I would
say our pitches of some type people
asking for time or favors introductions
whatever it might be a few things have
helped me a lot so for instance with
something like speaking engagements I
was chatting with my friend Josh
Waitzkin who's considered a chess
prodigies the basis of searching for
Bobby Fischer and so on amazing guy and
good at a lot of things especially
thinking and his rule was instead of
getting stuck in the middle negotiating
for different fees and travel and this
setting the other thing he only does and
actually right now he does zero which is
the best policy perhaps for a lot of
things he does either free four causes
groups he believes in and then full
retail that's it non-negotiable this is
my price list there is no discount in
any case that's at all so for speaking
I remember chatting with someone I won't
name but very well
and they said the further away from my
house it is the more it costs that's it
so they have prices they live on the
east coast they said if it's down the
street in New York City its X if it is
in the same state but requires more than
an hour it's Y if it's in the us
domestically outside of that and so on
and so forth
international they almost never do but
then there is a set price no negotiating
and speaking engagement could be almost
anything right now one that I've learned
recently which has been fantastic which
is actually in my newest book tribe of
mentors is from Kyle Maynard and you can
look him up separately but amazing
amazing amazing guy and he learned from
a CEO who used this framework for hiring
because the CEO as part of the process
would ask his employees to interview the
potential new hire and then he would
have them rank the prospect from 1 to 10
but he had a twist and the twist is
important it's the most important you
can't use 7 and what Kyle realized is
when he accepted certain invitations or
offers or business deals and he ranked
it as a 7 he was doing it out of
obligation or out of fear of missing out
or some other motivation that really
isn't or shouldn't be a driver for your
decisions once you have to rank
something a six or an eight six is C
grade that's barely passing that's a no
it's an eight you're really stoked okay
it's not like you for ik I'm on cloud
nine ten stoked but you're pretty stoked
you're really stoked all right so rank
opportunities invitations from one to
ten and you can't use a seven that's the
one that's really helped me a lot and I
picked that up very recently another
comes from a friend Derek Siver's who's
an incredible entrepreneur and musician
and writer and fill in the blank his
heuristic is if it's not a hell yes it's
a no which actually goes hand-in-hand
with Kyle's guideline but it's not a
hell you
[ __ ] yeah I want to do that it's a no
nothing in between
so you'll notice commonality with these
is nothing in between all right so
there's some aspect of nothing in
between so I try to in many cases make
binary decisions so if I'm going to
prepare for book launch yes I will do
media of certain types with these
following guidelines but otherwise say
if I'm on book deadline amount and I'm
writing 0 media even if there are good
opportunities because the great ideas
and the great opportunities die they get
crowded out because you say yes to too
many good things all right reasonably
competent people don't lose so to speak
in various aspects of their lives
because they pursue a lot of bad ideas
it's because they say yes to too many
kind of cool good things and then they
don't have space for the once every six
months or once every year opportunities
that come along they're like oh my that
is exactly what I want to do but it's
too late because their calendars full
alright so whenever possible try to say
no across the board to certain
categories of things so for me that
would be interviews say speaking
engagements or coffee meetings any type
of in-person meeting and I learned from
a very famous billionaire investor
indirectly because I was turned down for
a meeting I know him quite well and I
said hey you want to get together have
lunch and a couple of questions of that
XYZ and he said I'd love to
unfortunately I am on a no meeting diet
and I'm doing everything via email and
only when absolutely necessary phone but
I'm doing no meetings whatsoever for the
next six months because I realized it
was just too disruptive and I wasn't
able to focus on my projects so I will
very routinely
go on no meeting diets no conference
called diets no fill-in-the-blank diets
and people are incredibly understanding
for the most part and if someone isn't
understanding that also tells you
something very valuable that they are
highly sensitive reactive perhaps
shouldn't associate with them at all
they can't understand that which is very
non personal so those are a few of the
things that have helped me to get better
at saying no which historically I'm
actually not very good at I like to
please people I like to be liked but I'd
become much much better and it's by
having rules it's by having policies and
realizing that if you follow that policy
and you're afraid of missing all these
opportunities you can test it for a
month and then look back at what you
missed a month you can do almost
anything for a month and then you can
assess and 99 times out of 100 you're
gonna realize nothing catastrophic
happened in fact nothing bad happened
and look at all these good things look
at all these fun things look at all
these really high-impact things that I
was able to do hope that helps learn to
say no so what is one of the most
worthwhile investments I've ever made of
energy time whatever it might be I would
have to say creating my own real-world
MBA and for that some context way back
in the day I was pining after going to
to Stanford Stanford GSB Graduate School
of Business because I really wanted to
go there undergraduate I ended up not
going and then I thought wait but I can
get back to the pine trees and the
beautiful terracotta buildings for a
business school and it also be a nice to
your vacation that looks good on a
resume I went through the process of
applying twice I went through everything
and it always ended at the tour of
classes because I would find one or two
classes I loved there was one I think it
was called inside venture capital with
Peter Wendel which was fantastic but
then there were all of these
theoretically heavy abstract conceptual
classes that were really uninspiring to
me and I just felt demoralized didn't
know what to do so what I decided at the
time because I was also having lunches
with someone named Mike maples Mike
maples jr. who's a spectacular investor
and he would ask me for PR or a launch
marketing advice related to his startups
and I would ask him that
about deal structure why he chose one
startup instead of another and
ultimately I decided to wait a minute
why don't I take what I would have spent
on Business School which is $120,000 at
the time like $60,000 a year so 120 K
over two years and just create the Tim
Ferriss fund in quotation marks which
would be my real-world MBA and I would
ask Mike if I could invest alongside him
just small amounts of money the
assumption this is the most important
part being that I would lose the hundred
and twenty K it's a sunk cost right in
the same way that tuition it's gone
once you pay it's gone and you hope that
at business school or in my real-world
MBA the skills I would develop all the
things I would learn the people I would
meet the network that I would build
would be worth more than that 120 K over
time and right out of the gate I made a
stupid decision and lost the first 50k
what a dummy on the first investment oh
so I was just like oh okay
now what never Mike's saying that seems
a little aggressive and I was like no
man this is gonna be the next difficult
boom like shook my head and yeah
complete like walking dead immediately
and I continued then to refine things
and ultimately that led to early-stage
investments in Facebook Twitter müber
Alibaba you go down the list the 50-plus
companies over the next 10 years
following that because that I ended up
enjoying it and it worked out by far the
biggest financial wins of my life
probably forever quite frankly have come
from the initial experiment of doing a
real-world MBA where I expected to lose
all the money I put in 120 K over two
years and I just blows my mind so that
was the best investment I've ever made
and you can mimic it in other smaller
ways whether you want to or dream of
being a novelist a dream of being an
ABCD or e you can create that type of
real-world education
oh right should you write a book should
someone or anyone write a book I get
asked questions about launching books
all the time how can I make my book a
best-seller have you written a book no
I'm going to write a book have you
written any books before no why are you
writing a book and we get into this
conversation and ultimately I ask one
question and that is for the period of a
year can you make this your number one
priority for a period of at least a year
can this be your number one if you have
a company that means your business is
number two if you have a family that
means your family is number two can this
be your number-one priority for a year
that's the general litmus test because
if you put out a mediocre book or even a
good book a good enough book which by
the way equals shitty as Brian Grazer
legendary film and TV producer would say
it's more of a liability than a help
okay so a mediocre book is more of a
liability than no book at all you can't
take it back so as Michael Gerber told
me who wrote the e-myth revisited which
is a book that had a huge impact on me
before I launched the 4-hour workweek he
said if you're going to write a book
write a [ __ ] book meaning like you're
all in all of your chips are into this
book so how did I know that I should do
four hour workweek right was it that
obvious
was it cleared was I dying to be a
writer which by the way I don't think is
a necessary checkbox you don't have to
write the book yourself necessarily open
by Andre Agassi by the way
Olga C Andre Agassi was ghostwritten but
it was a collaboration that took a long
time and a lot of Andres time
beautifully written but nonetheless
required a lot of focus from him so you
can have a collaborator but my I suppose
hurdle was it was easier for me to get
it out of my head than it was for me to
live with it in my head all right
it was less painful to put it down than
to have it ricocheting inside my head
and I had all these experiences from
2004 to say end of 2005 where I was
restructuring and reformulating my
entire business to run without me
traveling the world for 18 months
without any set schedule meeting all
these case studies and I was teaching a
class at Princeton twice a year
sometimes in person sometimes remotely
in high tech entrepreneurship gross
sharing my findings about scaling a
bootstrapped business and that slowly
morphed into lifestyle design how to
create a business or career to allow you
to take advantage of the most valuable
non-renewable resource which is time so
I'm already giving these 2 to 3 hour
classes and I would take notes and over
time because one of the students said
why don't you just write a book and be
done with it as opposed to teaching a
class of 40 students which was actually
a snarky Princeton student response it
wasn't a real suggestion I don't think
nonetheless I had insomnia for many many
many many years and I couldn't get to
sleep because these chapter ideas would
come these stories would come to mind
and I just couldn't get to sleep without
jotting down a little note on a piece of
paper and I ended up with a huge pile of
paper on lessons learned and so on and I
knew that at least two of my friends and
there were two specific friends in mind
one who is trapped in a decent paying
job where he had no time disliked what
he was doing but he could he could
finally afford that nice car right so he
felt like he was trapped and then I had
a friend who had started his own company
who similarly is making decent money but
felt trapped in a monster of his own
making and I felt these notes would help
them okay
did not want to write a book at that
point actively did not want to write a
book alright but I felt a moral
obligation to share this material
somehow and a few of my friends who were
authors recommended that I explore the
path to publishing it and I made a few
assumptions going into it because keep
mind I did not wanna write a book I
assumed it was gonna be extremely
difficult and brutal to write the book
which it was and we're talking
moments of doubt I should throw in the
towel I am going to have a nervous
breakdown
repeatedly okay that is more or less
than the case for every book that I've
written I'm at five now okay
the second assumption was that I was
going to probably hate the book itself
which I did okay and that has been
largely true for every book I've done
assume that up until a year after the
book comes out you're gonna look at it
and be disappointed with what you've
produced given that the third assumption
was that I would write the book and if
it even changed the life of one or two
people that would justify all the pain
all the self-loathing all the loathing
of the book all of the opportunity cost
of putting it together right and that
last but not least it was easier for me
less painful for me to get it out and
throw a Hail Mary and hope for the best
then to keep it inside of me and wonder
what if okay so a lot of different
checkboxes and the book
keep in mind for our work week was
rejected by 27 publishers and then when
it was finally printed first print run
was about 10,000 copies you don't even
get national distribution with that
nobody really expected a whole lot and
then with the same amount of focus that
I put into the writing put into the
launch ended up hitting the New York
Times bestseller list and now it's
millions of copies in 40-plus languages
okay but I don't think you get to
millions of copies in 40 plus languages
trying to write a book for the world
that is going to help your business I
just don't think it happens I've never
seen it happen and instead check all the
boxes that I mentioned and I wrote this
book for two friends very specifically
and by personalizing it in that way by
talking to them in a in a very
conversational way we ended up with the
results that we had could have very
easily gone a different direction but if
you can listen to everything I've just
said and you think to yourself I should
write a book then by all means go for it
but for most people this doesn't mean I
am a great writer therefore
you need to be a great writer no I'm
just saying it was less painful for me
to put it out than to keep it in my head
all right what are some unusual habits
that I have or absurd things that I love
all right let's start at the top since I
spent a lot of time trying to be
analytical and rational I have a few
prized superstitions one is that I don't
use red ink for signing anything and I
want to say pick this up somewhere in
Asia but that could be completely
made-up I don't use red ink for signing
things even a check at a restaurant all
right the second would be I don't cheers
with water pretty sure I picked that up
from an Italian no cheering with water
so I'll actually fist pump other people
at a table which I did at a really fancy
dinner two days ago and people thought
it was very odd but everyone else had
wine I hadn't actually had drained my
glass that's another thing so even if
it's an empty wine glass no it has to be
full of alcohol and so I went around
just pumping other people's glasses of
wine pretty odd I would say let's see in
addition to that very personal it's not
a superstition I suppose it is it's more
of a good luck charm the number 555 is
very good luck to me because I finished
the last line of editing my second book
the 4-hour body looked up at the clock
in samovar teahouse in San Francisco and
Hayes Valley at the time and it's 5:55
and I love repeating numbers so 555 if
it shows up on my phone I always take a
screenshot of and if I look at my phone
and it's 553 554 I'll wait wait wait
screenshot so I always take a screenshot
of 555 another unusual habit I don't
think of it as unusual but people have
told me is unusual is leaving my phone
on airplane mode 80 to 90% of the day to
avoid distraction this is particularly
important when I go to bed so I will put
it on to airplane mode and it doesn't
come off of airplane mode until I
finished my morning routine because if I
wake up and I see a barrage of texts and
emergencies real or manufactured forget
about meditation forget about everything
else and I use a
patient timer on my phone 20 minutes
plus two minute exit phase roughly and
if I look at my phone to start that
timer and it's notification text and so
on forget about the quality of that
meditation session so very frequently my
phone is on airplane until I have
finished the first hour of my day my
boot up sequence and then I'm ready to
face whatever might otherwise make me
overly reactive many people do
intermittent fasting of 1618 hours but
I'll do 5 710 days fasting I'm not a
doctor don't play one on the internet do
not be stupid only do that with medical
supervision
I have many doctors at my disposal and I
have them to help me and supervise me
the kid that can be very dangerous if
you do it unsupervised and the last odd
thing that I like not to end on the
don't die fasting bit is using a
makeshift I shade when I go to sleep so
I travel with various types of eye masks
the sleep master being the best in my
opinion but it's very thick it's hot so
what I started doing when it was warm
and I wanted to cover my eyes so I
wouldn't get woken up too early is I
would take a t-shirt and a little bit
length wise guy so imagine I'm folding a
t-shirt lengthwise and then I'd lay it
lay the folded edge right here along my
nose so it's kind of covering my head
and tuck one side under my head so it's
pinned to the pillow let's go to sleep
that way so almost every night I go to
bed with a t-shirt tucked under one side
of my head kind of draped over this way
with the fold right here at the bottom
of my eyes so what are your unusual
habits or absurd things that you love
because as they say normal people just
weirdos you don't know well enough yet
so let me know what you want weird happy
guys this is Tim again just a few more
things before you take off number
this is five bullet Friday do you want
to get a short email from me would you
enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun for the weekend and five
bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm I'll
spell that out and just drop in with
your email and you'll get the very next
one and if you sign up I hope you enjoy
it this episode is brought to you by
helix sleep I recently moved into a new
home and when I needed beds where did I
go I went to helix and I paid for them
with my own monies I tried all sorts of
mattresses some of you saw me soliciting
feedback and ideas on social media I
tested a ton and I ended up on helix
they offer mattresses personalized to
your preferences and sleeping style
without costing thousands of dollars so
check it out
split sleep calm or slash Tim and you
can take their very simple two to three
minutes sleep quiz to get started that's
a diagnostic and they can build your
mattress from there and ensure that it
is something you will absolutely love
the quiz helps determine the type of
mattress that is best for you by asking
all sorts of questions about your sleep
behavior such as if you tend to lie on
your back side or stomach as well as
your body type for couples they can even
personalize each side of the mattress
their customer service is phenomenal my
assistant my researcher I had them all
test
and the customer service is really
outstanding the mattress arrives within
a week and the shipping is completely
free you can try the mattress then for a
hundred nights and if you're not happy
they'll pick it up and offer a full
refund so check it out to personalize
your sleep experience visit helix sleep
comm forward slash Tim and you can get
$50 off of your custom mattress check it
out
helix sleep comm forward slash temp this
episode is brought to you by zip
recruiter you may have heard them
everywhere they're growing like crazy
they're an innovative platform for doing
several things but especially improving
the hiring process making it slick and
elegant and easy one of the hardest
parts of running any business growing
any business is finding and hiring the
right team I've seen this firsthand in
close to a hundred startups now god I'm
getting old from all over the world at
different stages of growth and nothing
can quite drain your resources and cost
you time and money like making mistakes
in hiring Zipp recruiter develop their
own system and their own platform for
helping you to solve to the biggest
problems and bottlenecks for employers
posting jobs easily and then making it
even easier to find the best candidates
unlike other job sites zipper cruder
does in effect opposite of what you'd
expect so they do not depend on
candidates finding you their technology
finds the right candidate for you and in
fact more than 80% of the jobs posted on
zip recruiter return a qualified
candidate based on your criteria that
you select in just 24 hours
so no more juggling email reviewing
hundreds of unqualified candidates I've
been there done that don't recommend it
we're dealing with calls to the office
etc none of that simply screen rate and
manage your candidates all in one place
on zip recruiters dashboard
and is a listener of the Tim Ferriss
show thanks for that
zip recruiter wants to allow you to
start posting jobs and trying their
services for free so if you're thinking
of hiring somebody you need to find it
an executive assistant you need to find
it develop or whatever it might be
try it out just visit zip recruiter com
forward slash Tim and you can experience
just House of recruiter has been used by
businesses of all different sizes to
find the most qualified job candidates
again that's the zip recruiter comm a
forward slash Tim check it out and get
the spin
you